Happy Thanksgiving everybody while you
are sitting down to the turkey and the
stuffing and your purple haired lesbian
cousin who's going to yell at you for I
don't know voting for Dr Oz or something
we are here celebrating the day with the
greatest Thanksgiving Day memes take it
away
[Music]
[Applause]
very wholesome very uh that's great I
really like that that's that's my level
of humor
keep going
[Music]
[Music]
you have to wonder how many tries that
took him one is it a deep fake I sort of
don't believe he actually made it and
two how many tries like his his family
must have been just so angry like John
I'm just trying to have a nice
Thanksgiving we've been at this for two
hours we've almost got it Mom I almost
got the grape in the hole that was very
well done on my Thanksgiving dinner is
going to look after all this
one too how it's going to look delicious
[Music]
oh no
that's sick that's actually sick it's
okay you don't know him you don't know
him
that is legitimately
sadistic psycho Behavior
the bird is looking at a corpse of
another bird you're telling me that bird
doesn't have any recognition that that's
a bird I don't know that I believe that
like if you know some alien overlords
kept us as sort of pets or you know bred
us on the farm and then one day we walk
in and there's just a human just
twirling over a roasted roasting spit
you know and they said oh well probably
more like
right
I'm just there sort of staring at this
this corpse twirling in the fire that's
sick you're sick people if you want to
give a real gift a real good gift to
your friends and loved ones and
relatives you got to check out Black
Rifle coffee okay Black Rifle has all
the best Brewing gear thermoses mugs and
apparel designed for folks who love
country and coffee Black Rifle sources
the most exotic highest grade roasts
from around the globe all coffee roasted
here in the US by veteran-led teams of
coffee experts you can stuff your
Christmas stockings with all the latest
roasts from America's coffee for 10 off
with my code Knowles kwles better yet
sign your Secret Santa up for a coffee
Club subscription imagine the joy of a
pre-scheduled coffee delivery your
favorite roasts when you need them most
it's the gift that keeps on giving Black
Rifle coffee company is veteran founded
and operated they take pride in serving
coffee and culture to people who love
America every purchase you make with
Black Rifle helps support veteran and
first responder causes go to
blackrightfulcoffee.com use promo code
notes for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear
apparel or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription that's black
riflecoffee.com promo code Knowles kwels
for 10 off Black Rifle coffee supporting
veterans and America's coffee
[Music]
oh no
oh no
you know how it's gonna end
I'll follow you into the park
it wouldn't be as bad without the music
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'll be here
we'll laugh until we think we'll die
nothing new sweet to learn with you
that is the best one of all of them that
is so
cold-blooded because you know I mean
look the turkeys had a great life those
turkeys only had one bad day it's just
the only part of it that really is true
psycho behavior is what is the photo of
the of the turkeys next to the pan and
just saying you're next that that's the
one you think oh man something's gone
wrong here but otherwise look these
people gave the turkeys a Wonderful Life
and then the turkeys gave them a nice
dinner
Happy Thanksgiving
[Music]
[Applause]